April 1717 a ship battles for her life
in a fierce storm off the coast of
America she's fighting gale force winds
and power
the ship is the widow xx gun flagship of
one of the most notorious and successful
captains of the Golden Age of piracy
black sound Bellamy
belamis ship is no match for the storm
she capsizes and is ripped apart by the
angry seas 144 pilots a lot with her
their possessions weapons and millions
in looted treasures scatter across the
ocean floor the once proud widow is gone
forever for nearly 300 years the widow
and her secrets lay hidden buried in the
sands of Cape Cod until one man made it
his mission to find her Barrie
Clifford's quest for the lost pirate
ship and her treasures became the search
of a lifetime as a young boy growing up
on the cake
Barry became intrigued by the myths and
legends that he heard about the widow
well I spent a lot of time fishing and
hunting and as I get a little older I
became interested in diving and looking
for shipwrecks Barry first heard the
story of the widow from his uncle Bill
when he was just a small boy our
favorite story was the story of the
widow and Captain Sam Bellamy and chests
of treasure pirate pistols and all those
sorts of things they're just the story
of a pirate ship you know lost in my
backyard buried in the sand and this
doesn't get any better than that one day
we were talking about what to do next so
let's go look for the the widow
in 1982 Barry put a team together to
start diving but it was hardly x marks
the spot was very challenging diving
over 3,000 ships wrecked on ok it's well
documented that's the reason it's called
the graveyard of the Atlantic despite
these challenges barring his divers
continued hunting for anything
coins cannon Timbers that would lead
them to the Widder but after three years
of fruitless searching Barry began to
wonder whether his quest for the widow
was doomed people didn't really believe
this thing existed many people and we
were highly ridiculed at first for even
looking for it in all those lunatics
there's no pirate ship out there despite
hours of research and thousands of dives
the ship continued to elude them finally
his perseverance
just when it seemed like we couldn't go
on anymore
we went out one morning and sky sort of
black and it was almost surreal and we
dug a pit came up found big heavy round
object you didn't know what it was was
just very heavy and sort of all
encrusted like a big piece of rust and
we brought it up and there was a Bell
protruding from one side of it we
brought the Bell to our laboratory and
our conservators started working on it a
couple of days later one of the
conservatives called me up said you
better get down to the lab I said why
we just found a W on the Bell when
revealed the full inscription read the
Whydah Gally
17:16 Barry had the cast-iron proof that
he needed after more than five years of
searching the widow was his finding the
Bell was the proof positive Barry and
his team needed to authenticate the
wreck as the pirate-ship Twitter
the first known pirate ship and world
for Barry locating the Bell also enabled
him to begin mapping the site this is a
chart that shows where we've been
recovering material it's a archeological
grid and the ship came in and
the wind was driving it from this
direction the shoreline is over here
this is about 1500 feet from shore to
the spa the Whydah wreck covers an area
of seabed measuring over 40,000 square
feet our artifacts are scattered across
this area in what is known as a
discontinuous archaeological site as
each individual artifact is recovered
its position on the site is accurately
locked this enables Barrie to understand
the layout of the widow wreck
the Widder is the first authenticated
pirate shipwreck in the world she's
packed full of preserved relics or
artifacts for the next twenty three
years burying his team work to recover
these precious treasures with the winter
project we actually have the opportunity
to see how pirates really lived and died
we can almost not quite but almost
connect with them through the objects
they want sandal
the widow's artifacts the belongings of
her long dead pirate crew offer a unique
insight into the Golden Age of piracy
nearly 300 years ago
this is going to be discoveries that go
on forever I think and completely
understanding what we have and there's
touchstones to this secretive Democratic
outlaw subculture but who were this
people
you